I just find this hilarious frankly uh
hilarious in a dark morbid kind of way
so there's a controversy today after it
was revealed that the head coach of the
Buffalo Bills who's named sea
mcder a few years ago apparently he gave
an inspiring speech to his team where he
used the 911 hijackers as examples of
teamwork okay he called on the team to
work together as a team just like the
hijackers this is from AP and emotional
Buffalo Bill coach Sean mcdermit
acknowledged regret on Thursday for
crediting the 911 hijackers for their
coordination during a team meeting four
years
ago mcder had cited the hijackers while
stressing the importance of
commun stressing the importance of
communication mcder had cited the
hijackers upon realizing how this
message was being interpreted mcder said
he called a second meeting an hour later
to apologize to his players
um so there's a lot more details about
this but that that's the basic idea he
called all the team
together he had this whole apparently
this whole big speech about the about
the 911 hijackers and why they examples
of
teamwork and then he regretted it almost
instantly and uh apparently he looked
around and said wow this is not Landing
this this is this is not working out I
don't know I don't know why this is not
resonating
and he called the team back back like an
hour later and apologized to them and
now a couple years later he's
apologizing again here he is uh
yesterday at a press conference
addressing some of this I want to
reference
um the team meeting that has been
brought up uh my intent in the meeting
that
day was to discuss the importance of
communication and being on the same page
with the
team I regretted mentioning 9 in my
message that day and I immediately
apologized to the
team Not only was 911 a horrific event
in our country's
history but a day but a day that I lost
a good family
friend and so with that I'll turn it
over to answer any questions you might
have okay
so I'm just I'm trying get inside his
head so you
you you want to give a message inspiring
message about teamwork and like
communication and dedication and you
surrounding
911 that that's not so
bizarre but rather than going with the
First Responders and like firefighters
you went with the hijackers as the
example this is like if you run a
restaurant and you want to inspire your
line Cooks so you tell them to be as
Innovative and creative in the kitchen
as Jeffrey dmer
I mean it's like the worst possible
example you could possibly choose and
you you always have to wonder again I
this is why I always find these kind of
stories
fascinating um when somebody steps so
willingly into it and there are plenty
you know in this cancel culture age
people get in trouble for saying all
kinds of things that are pretty
innocuous and I don't think this guy
should be in trouble I don't think he
should get fired for it but this is you
know it is actually objectionable and
so in that case you have to wonder like
what is going through your head cuz
McDermot thought of this analogy he had
a whole speech I guess that he either
planned in his head or he wrote I don't
know had it all planned out and it it
didn't occur to you that maybe there
might
be you know at best mixed feelings on
the team about this kind
of you know Story I mean and you didn't
think maybe there could be more
appropriate examples of of teamwork than
911 hijackers what do green eggs and
your Christmas dinner have in common
well they both need a ham to be complete
not just any ham mind you make it a
spiral cut Heritage pork Masterpiece
from good ranchers it's the kind of ham
that'll steal the show at your family
gathering and guess what you get it for
free with any good ranchers subscription
that's a whopping $99 value that you get
for free in your first order simply
subscribe to any box and you'll get your
free holiday ham included in any order
the subcription is amazing you get $25
off every order free gift in every third
box and free shipping on express
delivery the best part is knowing
exactly where your meat comes from and
that's local American Farms head on over
to goodranchers.com subscribe today with
code Walsh to claim your free Limited
stock holiday ham uh before they sell
out but act fast this offer won't last
forever order before December 11th for
guaranteed delivery by Christmas head to
goodranchers.com use code Walsh when you
subscribe to get your free 10 PB holiday
ham don't settle for the same old
holiday Fair elevate your Feast with
good ranchers this year good ranchers
American Meat delivered hey team ga
around take a knee you know through the
history of the game there have been some
teams that have exemplified teamwork and
dedication and
communication 2007 Patriots the 1972
Miami Dolphins the 911
hijackers and look I also want to say
it's really nothing to be offended by
honestly like I you know the guy
shouldn't be fired as I said this is not
this is the kind of obviously 911 of
course is not funny it's a terrible
tragedy this kind of thing is like yes
it's it's funny because it's so it's so
absurd and when someone just says
something incredibly
stupid we should be able to as a society
say yeah that was really
dumb and just kind of laugh it off
especially if they acknowledge you know
people should be allowed to do that even
if it's something
pretty this is it's this kind of mistake
that probably most people wouldn't make
but
still um it should be possible for us as
a society to say wow you said that that
was dumb why the hell did you say that
you dummy and then the person can
respond you know what you're right that
was stupid I shouldn't have said it and
then we just move on that's it that's
all you have to
do especially with with football players
and football coaches because the other
thing you have to remember is that you
know these people are pretty stupid they
are and I say that as a football fan and
I don't mean any disrespect to them
they're very smart at what they do a
football coach is smart at strategizing
football games as far as that goes
they're brilliant I mean NFL
coach you know his way of drawing up
plays and all that I mean it's none of
us could could do that but they've spent
their whole lives thinking only about
that I mean the only thing that they've
thought about their entire lives really
is just football and so outside of that
they they don't know
anything which is fine they're
Specialists this is what they specialize
in but they know nothing outside of that
which is also why it's very silly when
we listen to any of these people you
know when they preach about politics or
social
issues uh when because when they when
they they're thinking only about a sport
and then they glance over for five
seconds at some other issue and give
their thought on it it's it doesn't it's
it's it's not going to be a well thought
out idea we know that if You' like to
see what else I have to say you can
access my full show by going to
dailywire.com or by going to the Matt
wall Show Twitter page hope to see you
there God speed